you can become proficient in any skill
in about 20 hours the problem is is that
people will wait a decade to start the
first hour you'd be amazed at how much
progress you can make if you cut down
the time between when you acknowledge
the work and when you start doing the
work and I think that over time in my
career what has happened is just that my
delay between when I need to do
something and when I start doing it has
just shrunk so that I can get to the
gain and proficiency that much faster
and then if you think about that over 10
years 20 hours and 20 hours and 20 hours
and 20 hours and 20 hours and 20 hours
by the end of that decade they're not
even recognizable